What will happen,
the Joe Rogan experience.
And it does seem that a,
that there is a particular model,
I want to say condemnation of male energy.
Do you think you can comes from a misunderstanding?
Yeah.
And I also think it comes from a big generalization to yeah,
it's easy to do,
right?
And if you're a woman who's had negative experiences with men,
maybe have dated man that had been physically abusive or maybe known men that
had been physically abusive and you,
you're around that and you just,
uh,
it's,
it's very convenient and very easy to just generalize and decide that all men
are negative,
masculine energy is negative and especially white males.
And if he say that you'll get props online,
people go like,
yes,
girl,
clap,
clap.
People get excited.
But those are also people that are shortsighted.
Like you want to make as many people,
your allies.
You can,
you want to make as many people,
your friend as you can.
And you have to understand that there's some people that are just wired
different than you.
There's some,
there's some girly girls and there's some really feminine men.
And then there's some masculine men and then it,
but everybody is okay as long as they respect you and they're kind to each
other.
But the problem is we associate certain behaviors and characteristics with
either negativity or hedonism or a toxic masculinity or someone being a bitch as
a man.
And that's,
these generalizations are often way more harmful and just it's just too
convenient and easy and lazy.
Yeah,
there is no simple way.
And when I think about my own attitudes in this area,
there is a degree of complexity because I've got young daughters,
I've got a two year old and a one year old,
right.
And there,
you know,
daughters,
so like,
but when they have a day,
um,
cause I'm staying in Los Angeles,
Gabby,
she's Mexican.
She used to be,
when I first moved out here and lived in my entourage lifestyle,
she used to look after the house and she used to think,
oh my baby,
my baby,
she loved me.
So,
and I'm like,
I'll take a matriarchal figure wherever I can find one.
And Gabby used to look after me,
she adored me and stuff.
I stayed friends with her yesterday.
She come around,
she bought like a like,
well I can only describe as a bikini for light.
My baby daughter,
I like that.
What a two year old that doesn't need like a,
like a bikini like top and I,
excuse me burping on the mic.
I like it.
For me,
I felt like I don't want to put my daughter in that,
that sort of in a way sexualizing the like that child and like coverage and also
a lot of the time like with my daughter,
I don't live with my wife,
particularly if our first child I'm like don't dress her up in little dresses
and stuff because she won't be out of like run around.
And I thought my God,
I'm not,
that's not that different from like the cliche of a male parent that wanted his
son and I didn't want to sign.
There would be no in particular.
I've loved this kid.
I love this kid regard.
You know,
it doesn't mean I love having the door adore her,
but like I am aware that these things of like dress a child this way,
dress a girl this way.
Our constructs fervor to what we were talking about again before about Michelle
Foodco we've got a lot done before we went live man.
But when we were talking about Michelle Fuoco,
what he exposes a lot is that there and a delusion guilt to lose is that a lot
of things that we take for granted as being normal or actually constructs and
when I say a child's bikini,
but there's no reason for at any child of any sex or gender to be wearing a
bloody bacchanal.
So a child with tits is a terrifying idea per for all but a very small and
terrifying percentage of the population.
So like that is an example of the external feminization of a child.
Like say when there's an argument of feminist argument of you know,
gender is a construct.
I can see,
oh yeah.
To a point is there is,
there are constructs cannot,
like my opinion is you can't argue with biology.
Chromosomes are doing what they're doing in the physical realm.
But like a,
I,
you know,
like being a father to a daughter has made me feel like I don't obviously,
and I know you have daughters or at least they thought three,
three doors.
Like I like,
I'm certainly very aware of,
I don't want to push them down some culturally prescribed avenue,
whether it's about their dress,
their sexuality or anything.
So I've got,
you know,
where do I,
where am I on that dial?
You know?
Yeah.
You got to just not put any pressure on them and let them enjoy their life and
let them find their path.
That's what,
it's weird.
It's weird,
right?
It's like I see people,
they're,
you know,
they're getting their,
their daughters to dress very,
very feminine with a little mini skirts and stuff when they're five years old
and high heel shoes.
I've seen little kids with high heel shoes.
It was very strange to me.
I don't like it.
Yeah.
What,
so you know,
but for me that is being sourced from like of we can extrapolate that to then
why should a 20 year old woman wear high heels?
I mean I've read cultural analysis,
I'm sure you have of law.
Well the lipstick is to emphasize the lips because it's rather than of the
vagina.
The high heels is to make a woman see more vulnerable and to accentuate aspects
of body shape.
And then this can be,
you know,
seen as evidence of the influence of Patriarchy that there's loads of areas
where I feel like,
why are we looking for shit to argue about in this area?
We're just human beings.
Most of us,
the most important people in our life up of the,
of the diff or a different gender or sex to us.
You know,
why we look for arguments,
but I can,
you can see the influence of cultural forces that are,
you
know,
not neutral.
Yeah,
you certainly can.
But I think it should be up to the choice of the person once they're an adult.
The real problem is putting pressure on them to dress one way or another.
And not letting them find their place.
But if a woman becomes,
you know,
whatever age you decide and she wants to wear high heels and a skirt because she
likes the way it looks like,
there's nothing wrong with that either.
And are,
are the demonization of sexuality is also a problem.
You know the,
yeah,
it is almost as much of a problem as people who will pray upon vulnerable
people.
The,
the p people,
people that think there's something wrong with being sexually attractive or
something wrong with being desirable or wanting to be desirable.
There's nothing wrong with that either.
And that kind of suppression,
the suppression of these feelings that you and this desire that you have,
it's very unhealthy as well.
It's a normal thing to want to be sexual.
It's a normal thing to want to look good.
If a girl looks good in a skirt,
a skirt,
and high heels and she likes to dress like that,
who the fuck is anyone to say there's anything wrong with that?
There's nothing wrong with it.
It's,
if that's what she likes,
that's fine.
Which isn't what's interesting to me is particularly um,
in really progressive ideology.
They look down upon women who wear short skirts and high heels and a lot of
makeup and you know,
open tops that show their boobs because they think that it's,
they're playing into the patriarchy or that there's somehow or another falling
into these gender traps,
but yet they celebrate that in transgender people they celebrate that and Trans
men that transitioned to women and then they,
they,
they really doll it up.
Then they're like,
you go girl.
Then they're celebrating the fact that this person is embracing these
traditional aspects of womanhood.
Will you see that a lot with,
you know,
people that are celebrating Trans Women.
So I find very fascinating
the aesthetics of a,
that sort of what would be perhaps could be referred to as sexualized dress or
like a it I suppose in males express expression,
expressive or Garish clothing,
jewelry,
tattoos in.
I understand in British culture that these are often indicators of class that
like that it's typically the lower down the clown class structure you are,
the more likely you are to dress in a way to exhibit if or like you know women
from a blue collar background dress in ways that are exposing reveal in men have
Larry cars and lots of tattoos and jewelry,
expressive ways of demonstrating wealth.
The higher you go up the class the more subtle,
the more dressed down you know labels or that sort of stuff.
You know.
So in British culture there's a different system of like a different system for
referencing it.
I wonder how that works in American culture with its sort of like it's evident
and much discuss racial divisions let certain things,
it seems like a subtle way of condemning particular types of womanhood that may
not just be sourced from dress this way for the male gaze.
It can also be a way of saying dressing that way as an indication of a lower
class background or of a particular type of ethnicity if there.
But there's also,
so
the reality of males and females is there's a lot of fucking jealous people and
there's a lot of women that just don't have the type of physical body that looks
good in a short skirt with high heels and you know,
a low cut shirt and they don't like when they see it in other women because they
don't,
they're not comfortable with their own bodies there.
That there's a reality of that.
I mean,
women get as much or more hate from women as they ever do for men.
And particularly if women find you to be too overtly sexual with the way you
dress or behave,
that you're,
you're,
you know,
you're damaging male,
female relationships,
you're damaging the dynamic particular office dynamics.
If there's one girl in the office that likes to tramp it up,
you know,
and she's a,
and all the guys are paying attention to her,
women will get mad at her.
I,
um,
did an interview a while ago where I sort of talks about like pet parent in our
kids,
me and my wife have a parent,
our kids.
And I said like,
uh,
you know,
it goes well,
I'll have to be a nice,
my wife is much the more dominant parent,
she's much more practical than I am.
Right.
And like,
stuff that got that got like really negatively written about poops set your
black coco.
She changes more diapers than I do and stuff.
Right?
I say,
look,
I don't change diapers or wherever.
It's just my wife,
you know,
regardless of our respective sexy is the more efficient dominant parents.
She's much more likely with like with me,
if my dog goes,
I want that chocolate.
The answer to for me is,
okay,
all right.
You know,
like,
I can't bear to see the,
the resistance,
the emotional exposure,
not concede much too early.
I tap out very quickly with,
with my two year old,
my wife is much more know that it's played a long game.
Let's bring up a child that's not governed by impulses like you.
And I spoke in fact to that gap or Matt Ada expert on addiction.
He's amazing.
And he says,
because of your own anxiety and pain from your own childhood,
with no disrespect to my magnificent parents,
uh,
like you can't handle seeing your kid suffer.
So you'd like straight away you bail and do what she wants and stuff.
Now they have like,
so there's so much complexity in the reality of our personal little domestic
relationship.
I'm certainly will not saying and everyone else should run their households in
that manner as well.
So help me God,
any man that changes it up,
you know?
But the way it was reported is like,
that's what happens I think in modern media is they change what you say,
then you have to defend what they said.
You sit and you feel that in white men,
I'd like,
you know,
I'm not saying that that because my wife is a woman,
she should take more domestic.
Gee,
I'm just saying that in our household she seems to have a set of attributes and
characteristics that make her take control of that aspect of parenting.
And it's like the,
the desire to judge,
condemn an object is the priority as opposed to,
yeah,
no one's looking to go on.
Yeah.
Who cares or what,
yeah.